I honestly I just feel like when we have
conversations about sex in marriage like
women have to be honest there are points
in your marriage where you have to make
an effort but you have to look at your
husband and say okay he needs to take
one for the team
like he needs me in this capacity and I
may not feel like it for the foreseeable
so let me Avail myself in the same way
you would want like your husband or your
partner to eval himself in whatever of
our scenario or even the same I just
feel like it it is not that uncommon for
a woman to not want to have sex because
when you become when you are a woman of
a house you've got a lot going on
especially if you work as well there's a
lot happening and you have babies and
stuff like that I just feel like
sometimes yes
like the wife is required to make an
effort she's not always going to feel
like it